le domaine de maison rouge
né de la distribution des terres qui
s'est opéré dans les années 1720 1730 le
domaine de maison rouge est intimement
liée à l'histoire des cultures
spéculatives dans le sud de l'île celle
du café puis celle du sucre les
bâtiments répondent à une disposition et
hiérarchiser la maison principale domine
la cour avec les arts gamas bordée de
bâtiments agricoles puis une autre
plateforme où se trouve le camp des
esclaves un escalier d'honneur mène à la
maison construite à partir de 1750
elle sera agrandie au fil des siècles et
des propriétaires de style néoclassique
la façade actuelle est recouverte de
planche ça va mon assemblée à l'ouest de
la maison se trouve une salle à manger
son office construit dans la seconde
moitié du 19e siècle dépendance cuisiner
logement de domestique participants au
bon fonctionnement de la propriété sont
situés à l'arrière de la maison il donne
sur un vaste verger comprenant aussi un
potager la maison domine toutes les
installations agricoles du domaine césar
gamas ou aire de séchage du café sont
les derniers vestiges de la grande
culture caféière du xviiie siècle du
camp des esclaves ne subsiste que
quelques ruines
installé dans les anciennes écuries du
domaine depuis 2008 le musée des arts
décoratifs de l'océan indien possède une
très riche collection de meubles textile
porcelaine et autres objets d'art classé
monument historique
mais en rouge et le dernier domaine
caféier du xviiie siècle dans tout
l'outre-mer français qu'ils soient
parvenus jusqu'à nous avec toutes les
traces de son implantation